hello everyone i am niha avasthi of msc
biotechnology here to present research
review or topic
genetic and epigenetic basis of scid
through multi-omnix approaches
analysis of the molecular etiology of s
of skin has led to the important
insights into the control of immune
cell development skin is the most severe
form of primary immunodeficiency disease
it is characterized by abnormality in
the function of immune system due to the
genetic defects in the development of t
cells skid is seen in infants and is
fatal if left untreated for the first
year of life here is a data from the
primary immune deficiency treatment
consumption
which is 47 centers around the u.s you
showing that treatment is very
successful if given at the younger age
less than 35 percent before baby
months before babies have started to get
serious infections
but these infections begin
and they certainly compromise survival
and this is even modern in modern data
in the latest decades
showing survival decreasing around 50
percent if infants have an active
infection at the time of their bone
marrow transplant
fortunately now we have newborn
screening for skin and it's based on
detecting these little circles of dna
called trecs
that are produced from the combination
of
t cell receptors that has to cut and
paste different pieces together in order
to generate the t cell diversity that
helps us fight infections and this
byproduct of t-cell recoil receptors
rearrangement produces a very handy
analysis for new bond screening and this
graph shows that newborn screening has
increased in a
diagnostic methods of skin
another determinant for survival of skin
is the
genotype
there are many different genes that end
up that interrupts digraph again
interpreted in graft again from the data
of primary immune deficiency treatment
consumption
consortium it that
is that the survival is the worst for
the gene called dclr
e
1c it's called the
artemis
gene
and mutation in this gene that produces
kid that has the worst survival of any
of the skin genotypes
the genes encodes a dna repair enzyme at
this repair enzyme is necessary in order
to accomplish the t and b and
d and b a cell receptor rearrangement
that are required to
make these t cells and b cells mature
so this is called a t minus b minus form
of scale and because dna breaks can't be
fixed these individuals also have
increased sensitivity to radiations
this type of skin has the poorest
survival because even after the
successful donor transplant v cells uh b
cell
immunity is rare due to which the t cell
transplant is incomplete secondly
alternative donor transplants have high
rates of rejections bigger immune
reconstitutions and increased
graft versus host disease thirdly
uh fourthly the dc
high dose alkaline alkylator
chemotherapy
leads to the short status poor tooth
development and increased mortality due
to which gene therapy may offer a bit
another type of scale in the in this is
the
cd45 deficient skin caused by the
uniparental diasome this type of a this
type of infants
surviving cd45 deficient scared patients
upd ser refers to the inheritance of two
copies of chromosome for segment
of chromosomes from one parent
these uh these are mutations
mutations that will be deleterious to
protein functions using svm
the number of
parentheses quantifies the likelihood
that a mutation will disrupt protein
functions
the cause of is
scared in in france is lack of protein
tyrosine phosphatase cd45
that was identified
through snp array and whole genome
sequencing
materials and methods
serum
antigen levels were determined by niflo
matri
lymphocyte proliferation was assessed by
measuring thymidine
incorporation into mononuclear cells
following culture with optimal
concentrations of indicated stimuli
then
cell sorting is done
by as the mutated and healthy cells are
used for
that are used for rt pcr and indicated
cytochip analysis were isolated from
frozen peripheral blood mononuclear
cells
pb
pbmc using facts vintage by sorting
cells incubated with unlabeled unleveled
mouse antibody to hla dr2 followed by
inco incubation with
neon normal coat serum and staining with
rpe good mouse
anti-mouse antigen sorting is done
because
because of available patients frozen pb
mc obtained post bone marrow transplant
but before t cell development and
contained cd45 maternal lymphocytes
then isolated
rna is used for c dna synthesis
in rtpcr analysis
and cd45 and beta acting transcripts
were then quantified by rtvcr with the
master master cycles in appendrosis
then followed by cd45 sequence analysis
is done in this
in this pc are amplified with pair with
primer
pairs that generates overlapping
products
spamming the the full length cd45
variants
variant one transcript coding sequences
then total genomic dna individuals and
individual amplified dna samples were
each ampli
purified fragmented biotin labeled and
hybridized to a cytogenetic
uh whole genome whole genome array
after that
exam sequencing and bio bio for
bioinformatic analysis is done
the metadata are collected and the dna
libraries are prepared sample
preparation and sequencing were done by
expression analysis single nucleotide
variants and indel variants were
identified a database created for the
from the from the annotated data sets
for the maternal upd analysis alleles
that fulfill the requirements were
identified and requirements were
heterozygous
a heterozygous in mother sample
homozygous for wild type alleles in
father's sample
then homozygous for hete wild type
alleles in other unrelated samples in
the data sets
then formosa a homozygous for
alternative alleles in child sample
another type of parental update analysis
were done by the requirements or
followed by heterozygous in father
sample homozygous for wild type in
mother sample
then homozygous for wild type alleles in
unrelated samples of data sets
followed by homozygous for alternative
alleles in child samples
the tools were tools are used for
identifying high
confidence mutations from the raw dart
drop sequence data for the phenotype of
of missense mutations sequence based and
structure based informations on each
mutations
psi blast is used for structure for
homozygous homologs for the unipod
sequences in the datas in the database
and to calculate the position specific
scoring matrix
for each sequence
the
homologs with great
with greater than 35 percent sequence
identified to their queries were aligned
through alignments and the score for
each sequence positions is calculated
finally mutations were mapped to protein
structures using pro profile profile
alignments
search methods
results with patients that lacks cd45
expression when gone through this flow
cytometric analysis uh through uh
peripheral blood lymphocytes uh at the
presentation
revealed normal numbers of b and nk
cells but dramatically reduced number of
t cells
moreover a few t cell present
were found to be non-functional as they
were unresponsive and mitogenic
stimulation automatogenic stimulation
3d45 is essential for t cell development
and t-cell receptor signal transductions
and had previously been identified into
fatal cases of skin
the sangha sequencing revealed that the
patient's mother was heterozygous for a
nonsense mutations at the position 1618
of the coding sequence in exxon exon 14
of the cd45 gene that created a stop
codon at uh amino acid 540 however no
mutations were observed in the coding
regions of either beta pattern cd45l
alleles
so this finding suggested that either
one copy of the parental chromosome
elementing the cd45 locus and the
patient inherited two copies of the
mutant matter maternal cd45 alleles
this is the sangha analysis of the cd45
analysis of the patient
and the parents the schematic uh depicts
the dom
domains of cd45 including alternatively
supplies exxon
that gives rise to rn ro informs
transmembrane domains and
domains and phosphatase domains the
position of nonsense mutations is marked
by
marked and the change in nucleotide
sequence
and amino acid sequence at the bottom
in the patient in the patient
this anchor sequence traces on genome
dna from the parent and
patients can be seen in
it is caused by the duplication of the
mutant alleles
snp arrays are performed on gene genomic
dna from
ebv lines derived from the lymphocytes
of parents and patients resulting that
there there are no changes in the copy
number across cd45 locus on chromosome 1
due to the due to which the patients had
entire either inherited two
two entire copies of maternal chromosome
one or two copies of the region
compromising
the maternal cd45 mutations
whole genome array analysis revealed
that iso
disomi was also evident in other primary
blood cell types which are derived from
embryonic mesoderm as well as in
epithelium which is derived from the
embryonic ectoderm
in this uh in this graph we can see that
copy number and allele peak analysis of
various cell populations from the
patients and parents and parents
patients are seen
analysis of copy number and allele p
allele peaks in ebv
immortalized b cell is depicted the
y-axis depicts the dna number
copy number and allele peak
allele peak panels
normally shows three brands representing
all homozygous and heterozygous allele
calls
note that
the
copy number panels reveal reveal two
copies of each chromos gene on
chromosome one
but
show only two bands with
with loss of middle heterozygous and
and across the entire chromosome
indicative of upd chromosome indicates
that uh indicates for each or autosome
and x chromosome
are shown on the x-axis copy number
and allele peak analysis are depicted
from chromosome one neutrophil
lymphocytes and buccal epithelium
from the from the patients all these
analysis are performed using
the whole genome arrays
only
thank you
so due to this
skid
skid can be treated by gene therapy
and bone marrow but more specifically
gene therapy because
it it through that through that complete
form of b cells on t cells
transplantations can
that's all for myself thank you